¿Por qué diablos deberíamos hacerlo?
Hace 12 años,
di una charla TED nombrando 10 causas posibles del fin del mundo.
Somos muy vulnerables a los caprichos de nuestra propia galaxia.
Un único e inmenso asteroide podría eliminarnos para siempre.
Para sobrevivir tenemos que conquistar otros planetas.
Piensen qué trágico sería
si todos los logros de la humanidad desaparecieran de repente.
Y hay otra razón para esta exploración:
es parte de nuestro ADN.
Hace dos millones de años, los humanos evolucionaron en África
para luego, poco a poco extenderse por todo el planeta
y adentrarse en tierras salvajes más allá de sus hogares.
Lo llevamos dentro.
Y prosperaron haciendo eso.
Algunos de los mayores avances de la civilización y la tecnología
surgieron porque exploramos.
Es cierto que podríamos hacer mucho bien con el dinero que se necesita
para establecer una próspera colonia en Marte.
Y claramente debemos hacer mucho más para el cuidar a nuestra madre Tierra.
Y sí, me preocupa que pudiéramos estropear Marte
de la misma manera que hicimos con la Tierra.
Pero piensen por un momento lo que teníamos
cuando John F. Kennedy dijo que íbamos a llevar al hombre a la luna:
animó a toda una generación a soñar.
Piensen que emocionados estaríamos por ver un amartizaje.
Tal vez entonces, al mirar de vuelta a la Tierra
entenderíamos que está hecha por un pueblo en lugar de por muchos;
y tal vez entonces, al mirarla,
mientras lucháramos por sobrevivir en Marte,
nos daríamos cuenta de lo preciosa que es nuestro madre Tierra.
Permítanme hablarles de la extraordinaria aventura que estamos a punto de emprender,
pero primero,
compartiré algunos datos fascinantes acerca de dónde vamos.
En esta imagen se aprecia el tamaño real de Marte comparado con la Tierra.
Marte no es nuestro planeta hermano.
Tiene mucho menos de la mitad del tamaño de la Tierra,
y sin embargo, a pesar de ser más pequeño,
la superficie habitable marciana
es equivalente a la superficie habitable terrestre
ya que la Tierra está cubierta por agua.
La atmósfera marciana es muy tenue
-- 100 veces más delgada que la terrestre --
y no es respirable, tiene un 96 % de dióxido de carbono.
Hace mucho frío allí.
La temperatura media es de - 62 °C
aunque varía ampliamente.
Un día marciano es casi tan largo como un día en la Tierra,
más unos 39 minutos.
Las estaciones y los años en Marte son dos veces más largos.
Y para cualquiera que quiera ponerse alas y volar un día,
dada la menos gravedad que en la Tierra,
Marte se vuelve el tipo de lugar
donde se puede saltar por encima del auto en lugar de rodearlo.
Cómo se puede ver, no se puede decir que Marte sea similar a la Tierra,
pero es con diferencia
el segundo lugar más habitable en todo nuestro sistema solar.
Aquí está el problema.
Marte está muy lejos,
mil veces más lejos que nuestra propia luna.
La Luna está a 400 000 km de distancia
y los astronautas del Apolo llegaron allí en tres días.
Marte está a 400 millones de kilómetros
y nos hará falta ocho meses para llegar allí, o 240 días.
Y eso es solo si despegamos un día muy en particular,
en un momento muy específico,
una vez cada dos años,
cuando Marte y la Tierra están alineados de tal manera
que la distancia que el cohete tendría que recorrer sería la más corta.
240 días es mucho tiempo para pasar encerrado con tus colegas en una lata.
Y mientras tanto, nuestro historial de logros por llegar a Marte es pésimo.
Nosotros, los rusos, los europeos, los japoneses,
los chinos y los indios,
hemos enviado juntos unos 44 cohetes allí,
y la gran mayoría no han llegado a su objetivo o se estrellaron.
Solo un tercio de las misiones a Marte han tenido éxito.
Y por ahora, no hemos tenido un cohete lo suficientemente grande
como para llegar allí de todos modos.
Una vez tuvimos ese cohete, el Saturno V.
Un par de Saturno V nos hubieran llevado hasta allí.
Fue la máquina más impresionante jamás construida por el hombre,
y el cohete que nos llevó a la Luna.
Pero el último Saturno V se usó en 1973 para lanzar la estación espacial Skylab,
y decidimos construir el transbordador espacial
en lugar de continuar la carrera a Marte después de alunizar.
El cohete más grande que tenemos hoy
tiene solo la mitad del tamaño suficiente para llevarnos a Marte.
Así que llegar a Marte no será fácil
y esto plantea una cuestión interesante:
¿Cuándo aterrizarán allí los primeros humanos?
Algunos expertos piensan que si llegamos allí en 2050,
sería un gran logro.
La NASA parece decir en la actualidad que llegaremos a Marte en 2040.
Tal vez sea posible.
Creo que el hombre puede llegar a la órbita de Marte en 2035,
pero, francamente,
no creo que querrán enviar un cohete a Marte en 2035
porque ya estaremos allí.
Vamos a aterrizar en Marte en 2027.
Y la razón es
que este hombre está decidido a hacerlo realidad.
Se llama Elon Musk y es el CEO de Tesla Motors y SpaceX.
De hecho me confirmó el aterrizaje en 2025,
pero, Elon Musk es más optimista que yo,
y eso es decir mucho,
así que le doy un margen de un par de años.
No obstante,
tienen que preguntarse,
¿puede hacerlo realidad para el año 2025 o 2027?
Veamos qué significa una década para Elon Musk.
¿Dónde estaba hace 10 años?
Ese es el auto eléctrico Tesla.
En 2005, muchos en la industria automovilística decían
que no íbamos a tener un auto eléctrico decente en los siguientes 50 años.
¿Y dónde ocurrió eso?
Este es el cohete Falcon 9 de SpaceX,
llevando seis toneladas de suministros a la Estación Espacial Internacional.
Hace 10 años,
SpaceX no lanzó nada, no mandó un cohete a ningún lugar.
Por lo tanto creo que merece apostar
por la persona que revolucionó la industria del automóvil
en menos de 10 años
y la persona que creó toda una empresa aeroespacial en menos de 10 años
para que nos lleve a Marte antes de 2027.
Ahora, hay algo que deben saber:
los gobiernos y los robots ya no controlan este negocio.
las empresas privadas conquistan el espacio
y estarán encantadas de llevarles a Marte.
Y esto plantea otra gran pregunta:
¿Podemos realmente vivir allí?
La NASA a lo mejor no podrá llegar allí hasta el año 2040,
o a lo mejor nosotros podemos llegar allí mucho antes que la NASA,
pero la NASA tiene un enorme mérito porque averigua cómo podemos vivir allí.
Veamos el problema de esta manera.
Esto es lo que necesita para vivir en la Tierra:
alimento, agua, refugio y ropa.
Y esto es lo que necesita para vivir en Marte:
todo lo anterior, más oxígeno.
Así que primero, vamos a ver la cosa más importante de la lista.
El agua está en la base de la vida tal como la conocemos
y es demasiado pesada para llevarla de la Tierra a Marte para sobrevivir,
así que tenemos que encontrar agua
si queremos que la vida en Marte sea un éxito.
Y si nos fijamos en Marte, se ve muy seco,
parece que todo el planeta es un desierto.
Pero resulta que no lo es.
El suelo marciano, por sí solo, contiene hasta un 60 % de agua.
y varios satélites que mantenemos todavía en la órbita de Marte nos han demostrado
-- por cierto, esta es una fotografía real --
que muchos cráteres en Marte contienen una capa de hielo.
No es un mal lugar para asentar una colonia.
Aquí se ve una pequeña excavación hecha por la sonda Phoenix en 2008,
que muestra que justo por debajo de la superficie del suelo hay hielo;
esa cosa blanca es hielo.
En la segunda imagen,
tomada unos cuatro días más tarde que la primera,
se nota que parte se está evaporando.
Los satélites también nos dicen
que hay enormes cantidades de agua subterránea en Marte
y también glaciares.
De hecho, si solo el hielo de los polos marcianos se derritiese
la mayor parte del planeta estaría sumergida bajo 9 metros de agua.
Así que hay mucha agua allí,
pero la mayor parte está congelada y bajo la superficie
y se necesita mucha energía y mano de obra para obtenerla.
Este es un dispositivo inventado en la Universidad de Washington en 1998.
y es básicamente un deshumidificador de baja tecnología.
Y resulta que la atmósfera de Marte cuenta a menudo con 100 % de humedad.
Así que este dispositivo puede extraer toda el agua que los humanos necesitarán
simplemente de la atmósfera marciana.
Luego tenemos que preocuparnos por lo que vamos a respirar.
Francamente, me sorprendió mucho
descubrir que la NASA ha resuelto este problema.
Se trata de un científico del MIT llamado Michael Hecht
que ha desarrollado esta máquina, Moxie,
-- me encanta esta cosa --
es prácticamente una pila de combustible invertida
que aspira la atmósfera de Marte y bombea oxígeno.
Y hay que recordar que el CO2,
-- el dióxido de carbono, que constituye el 96 % de la atmósfera de Marte --
el CO2 es, básicamente un 78 % oxígeno.
La próxima gran sonda que la NASA enviará a Marte en 2020
tendrá uno de estos dispositivos a bordo,
y podrá producir suficiente oxígeno
para mantener a una persona con vida indefinidamente.
Pero el secreto de esto,
-- y esto es solo una prueba --
es que esta cosa fue diseñada desde el primer momento
con un factor de escalabilidad de 100.
A continuación, ¿qué comeremos?
Bueno, emplearemos la hidroponía para cultivar los alimentos,
pero no podremos cultivar
más de un 15 a un 20 % de nuestra comida allí,
al menos no hasta que haya agua corriente en la superficie marciana
y tengamos la oportunidad y la capacidad real de plantar cultivos.
Mientras tanto,
la mayor parte del alimento llegará desde la Tierra, deshidratada.
También necesitamos cobijo.
Para empezar, podemos usar edificios hinchables, presurizados,
así como los propios módulos de aterrizaje.
Pero esto en realidad solo funciona durante el día.
Hay demasiada radiación solar y proveniente de los rayos cósmicos,
así que realmente tenemos que vivir bajo la superficie.
Resulta que el suelo de Marte,
por lo general, es perfecto para la fabricación de ladrillos.
Y la NASA ha descubierto la manera de hacerlos también.
Se añaden polímeros plásticos a los ladrillos,
se colocan en un horno de microondas,
y así se construirán edificios con paredes muy gruesas.
O podemos elegir vivir bajo tierra en cuevas o en conductos de lava,
porque hay un montón.
Y por último, la ropa.
En la Tierra tenemos encima kilómetros de atmósfera,
lo que ejerce 6,8 kg de presión sobre nuestro cuerpo en cada momento
mientras estamos constantemente luchando con ello.
Marte apenas tiene presión atmosférica.
Dava Newman,
científica en el MIT,
ha creado este traje espacial elegante.
Nos mantendrá a salvo y bloqueará la radiación
lo que nos permitirá mantenernos calientes.
Así que pensemos en esto por un minuto:
Alimento, refugio, ropa, agua, oxígeno.
Podemos hacer esto.
De verdad podemos.
Pero todavía es un poco complicado y un poco difícil.
Y esto nos lleva al siguiente paso,
-- un paso muy importante --
vivir bien en Marte.
y eso significa la terraformación del planeta:
de modo que sea similar a la Tierra,
re-diseñar todo el planeta.
Eso suena muy presuntuoso,
pero la verdad es es que la tecnología para hacer lo que digo ya existe.
En primer lugar tenemos que calentarlo.
Marte es increíblemente frío porque tiene una atmósfera muy tenue.
La respuesta está aquí, en los polos marcianos,
ya que ambos están cubiertos
con una increíble cantidad de dióxido de carbono congelado, o hielo seco.
Si lo calentamos, sublimará directamente en la atmósfera
y este fenómeno la espesará del mismo modo que ocurre en la Tierra.
Como sabemos,
el CO2 es un gas de efecto invernadero increíblemente potente.
Mi método favorito para hacerlo es construir una vela solar gigante
y enfocarla, más o menos como un espejo,
empezando por el polo sur marciano.
A medida que el planeta gira, todo ese hielo seco, se calentará,
sublimará y se liberará en la atmósfera.
De hecho, no hará falta mucho tiempo
para que aumente la temperatura en Marte;
probablemente menos de 20 años.
Ahora mismo,
un día perfecto en el ecuador,
a mediados de un verano marciano
la temperatura puede alcanzar los 21° C
para luego bajar a - 73 °C por la noche.
(Risas)
Estamos apostando por un efecto invernadero inmediato:
con un suficiente aumento de la temperatura
para que gran parte de ese hielo marciano,
especialmente el que está bajo la superficie, se derrita.
El resto es pura magia.
A medida que la atmósfera se espesa, todo mejora.
Habrá mayor protección contra las radiaciones,
más atmósfera mantendrá al planeta y a nosotros más calientes,
por lo que tendremos agua potable, algo que permite el cultivo.
Más evaporación en el aire significará otro potente gas invernadero.
Lloverá y nevará en Marte.
Una atmósfera más densa creará suficiente presión
para renunciar a los trajes espaciales.
ya que solo hacen falta 2,2 kg de presión para sobrevivir.
Finalmente, Marte se parecerá mucho a la Columbia Británica de Canadá.
Todavía tendremos que lidiar con el difícil problema
de hacer que la atmósfera sea respirable,
y francamente eso solo se logrará en 1000 años.
Pero los humanos somos unos seres increíblemente inteligentes y adaptables.
No hay manera de saber qué logros tecnológicos alcanzaremos
y lo que llegaremos a saber que podemos hacer con nuestros propios cuerpos.
Hoy en día, estamos a punto de poder controlar nuestra propia genética,
lo que están haciendo los genes en nuestro cuerpo,
y, desde luego, finalmente controlaremos nuestra propia evolución.
Podríamos llegar a tener una especie humana terrestre
ligeramente diferente a la especie de humanos marcianos.
Pero ¿qué harán allí? ¿Cómo vivirán?
Será como en la Tierra.
Alguien va a abrir un restaurante,
otro una fundición de hierro.
Alguien rodará documentales en Marte
para venderlos en la Tierra.
Algún tonto lanzará un programa de televisión.
(Risas)
Habrá compañías de software,
habrá hoteles, habrá bares.
Lo cierto es que será el evento más perturbador de nuestra vida,
yo creo que va a ser el más inspirador.
Pregunten a cualquier niña de 10 años si quiere ir a Marte.
Los niños que ahora están en la escuela primaria optarán por vivir allí.
¿Recuerdan cuando el hombre llegó a la Luna?
Cuando eso sucedió, la gente se miraba y decía:
"Si podemos hacer esto, podemos hacer cualquier cosa".
¿Qué van a pensar cuando realmente colonicemos Marte?
Más importante,
seremos una especie de viajeros espaciales.
Y eso significa que sobreviviremos sin importar lo que pase en la Tierra.
Nunca seremos los últimos de nuestra especie.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)